this week conflict zone is in telling
the capital of Estonia I'll guess his
prime minister Taavi Ravus who says NATO
needs to do more to deter Russia but if
that call his Western allies will answer
carrier a bus welcome to conflict zone
the brexit boat is being viewed as a
disaster for the European Union to what
expand is it a disaster for your country
well as all others we are also of course
disappointed by this decision but we
definitely accept it as it is there is
no other choice it has been a Democratic
choice by the British people and now of
course we need to look for the future
what are they so let's talk about the
future let's talk about the future in
the brexit a threat to the very future
of your country well not more than any
other your country but but of course if
we look at the british rule in e it has
been significant and it's the lease
today significant of course they are
still members but they have been looking
for a student perspective they have been
like minded in issues like economic
development they have been very much
pro-trade just like Estonians they have
been very much a pro single market too
just like cast areas but also of course
their views on geopolitics are very
similar Jesus if this is as important
what is the threat for the future of
Europe you are a member of the European
Union but what are you thinking when you
are thinking about the brexit and the
consequences of the invention of the
European Union the reality well I don't
expect this European Union to be
destroyed by these developments or or I
don't see those kind of apocalyptic
scenarios as as some think should be now
following I think simply that EU will be
well somewhat smaller because an
essential part of Europe has said that
they no longer want to be part of it of
course there is huge difference whether
UK will remain as a close friend as a
close partner as close ally or will they
be
the ideas that the UK should be taken
further away and there should be this
sounds very diplomatic that's your duty
being a prime minister but the reality
is that the brexit symbolized something
which is more or less a daily experience
also in other countries we have a
nationalism which is increasing we have
the democratization which is increasing
example Poland what changes are
absolutely necessary from your point of
view if the European Union would have a
future and is going to survive well
first of all I think it would be wrong
to blame EU for the choice that Brits
have made I think that was their choice
they choose this way point we will have
no choice then event to accept it tend
to live with it but of course EU leaders
despite the country should always not
only because of this current
developments but but it should always
look very closely at the developments
with populist parties we all know that
populist can take us to the consequences
that nobody actually wishes and I think
it's not very incorrect to say that
breaks it is one of those cases were big
part of the people voting to exit EU
we're actually following the the
promises or slogans of four other
populist politicians and and the the
messages they were given were as we see
now proven wrong so how quickly should
the UK leave the European Union well
David Cameron made it very clear that he
will not be the prime minister to post
this a notification for in Samba the
party will have exactly did a little
helpers are weekly well of course too
long delays will keep this period of
uncertainty uncertainty
in the air but but I think that it would
be wrong for European Union to push to
Britain away by saying that you know you
should post the notification very soon
you should not think over what are they
it's very understanding what you are
telling me now very others also know
it's understandable we you're saying the
UK has not to be pushed okay this is one
perspective the other one is how long
the UK can play this game in which a
vacuum is not starting only for one side
but also for all the other countries in
Europe the economy in Europe and the
European Union by itself so what would
you say would be the time where time is
running out well as I'm not in position
to set the date for the next British
Parliament but what I can say is that
once the next government in UK is in
office they should take this as their
first priority in a way to make sure
that they have a clear view what will
happen next what is the British position
what kind of union with you would
Britain like to have of course as I said
delay is not a good thing but but
pushing the new British government to do
things in their first days in office
that the perhaps are not ready to do yet
would be wrong I think we should give
them enough time to come with a proposal
that is in the interest of British
people and of course as good as possible
for you as well and it is going to boost
your skeptics across Europe or bring u
leaders more focus on explaining what
Europe means explaining what Europe
means is always necessary Australia as
an experience of of government always
explaining why we need to do one or a
thing no government in Estonia
throughout the 12 years where we have
been members of EU even more than 12
years for now no government during that
time has blamed Brussels for things that
we actually have this
tied it together are the government's
doing there sometimes and and I think it
is the easy path to take it's the more
popular path to take to say that you
know those guys in Brussels they decided
the soulful institutions or whatever the
negative abilities are a negative image
of the European Union is due to the
politic of the Member States and of the
government's who are saying we are not
responsible Brussels is responsible
without telling the people that Brussels
the twinks you a exactly in the state I
think it is very important to know that
processes are the 28 member states who
take the decisions together and not
always the additions are a popular I
mean you're a past deal with a lot of
crisis but if we look at the crisis one
by one we can find very easily that none
of those crises are actually
existentially EU crisis but they are
sold by EU and and if those frontline
countries were hit by this and a crisis
alone without the EU crisis solving
ability they would be hit much harder so
this is why we need to explain how
things work and why we are doing this
and what would be the consequences was
not worry let's try to invent the
European Union and a few years there is
a discussion due to the decision of
Great Britain one side is saying we need
more a power in the European Union we
need more power in the institutions and
the other side is saying no this is now
a moment where we need less we have to
return to the decision of the national
States what is your opinion on that well
I think pushing the gas pedal on on
taking Europe very federal right now
would perhaps give negative signals for
some of those countries who who are more
skeptic about it but what I do you think
we should do is to go further with the
plans we already have there are things
that we should you know take to the next
level including the single market that
in theory we have for 500 million people
without Britain that will be 450 million
or so but in practice we still know that
if I want to watch my favorite TV show
in Berlin with my iPad I can have the
internet connection very easily but
there might be job blocking saying that
you don't have enough rights to see this
estonian TV show a very important issue
but let's talk really about principles
mr. Schultz the president of the
Parliament said we need now a government
which is elected by the European
Parliament we need reforms which are
really bringing the future also as as an
idea we can't continue to discuss only
roaming questions and others do you
agree that the story of Europe needs a
new input I think that we have clearly
28 government leaders around the table
who have been all democratically elected
I don't think that we think about the
European Union it was no element of
European you yeah commissioners I mean
surely but but of course it would be
positive to have the EU commissioners
all doing like like we had in in Estonia
that the the person applying for EU
Commission post that was decided by the
Australian Government to nominate him
for four young clunker but he took a
mandate from the people by running to
the European Parliament he got very very
good result you are prime minister
elected by your Parliament the same idea
could should be also in Strasbourg and
Brussels I mean we are talking about the
u.p union dedicated with democratic
standards so if the idea of mr. Schultz
that it's time that the Parliament is
selecting an own government in this idea
I'm not a scientist yeah i'm not sure if
this is the main issue actually watch it
the native maybe she is to talk about
the future of Europe not the future of
European structures what is there is a
different issue to talk about mooch of
your first better functioning single
market second more free trade you know
people in Munich still need to pay ten
percent tax customs tax for their ex
series bmw's or people living in in
Stuttgart need to pay ten percent duty
tax for their GLS or or m/l Mercedes so
how come this is in the interest of
German people or how I always may ask
you something listening to you I feel
that the European Union is principally
an economic idea I thought that in the
21st century it's also a question of
democracy of values so what's about that
well i have only mentioned two things
why what we should take further i think
in terms of common values also as a
Peace Project EU has been a tremendous
success if we look at the unity of 28 if
we look at the how often the leaders of
EU countries discuss all kinds of matter
including security which is not
self-evident in today's Europe we see
one European country being recently two
years ago partly occupied we still see
we have seen during this year we have
seen more than two hundred casualties by
Ukrainian forces but these kind of
things are not self-evident lost the
role of European Union as a union as a
security providing institution is also
ok so let's talk about this issue before
the brexit boat on a task said to the
this external enemies will be opening
champagne if written boats to leave do
you think letting me put in cracking the
champagne well I'm not certain of his
drinking habits and how it was that guy
that you know what I'm doing it tougher
of course the other I think it's quite
clear that 23rd of June referendum
results we're positive positively taken
by those people who think that Europe
should be fundamental week I of course
that was a sad day for those who are
true believers in European unity and a
good day for those who position
themselves as our opponents or perhaps
even enemies so certainly there is some
logic behind that thought that Thomas
you mention it I really worried about
military aggression from the Russians
like in Ukraine well in Ukraine the
military aggression is is a reality but
are you worried you're the prime
minister of your country that this could
happen to your country that the Russians
would attack you what would it take yeah
yes taenia is a member of nature and you
can't teach unite the security situation
of office terenia Germany the UK united
states so attacking any NATO countries
would be attack against all and this has
asked that I ask you if you being the
prime minister of Estonia are you afraid
that Russian could military intervened
in your country is that a danger which
is increasing well I don't think that
direct attack against NATO is likely in
the very near future and we have to keep
sending credible messages that NATO is
in addition to the articles in addition
to the political commitments by the
leaders of all NATO countries also
presented and also tried it the last
time promise I'm asking you not about
NATO I am asking you about your country
but my country is later there's no she
is a member in NATO and it's busy data
that I would have asked this also the
German Chancellor do you think that
there is an increasing danger that
Russia would attack this country well
what is very important to understand is
that there is not my country without
nature my country is every bit as nature
as Germany my country is every bit as
NATO as us so attacking Estonia would be
attacking Germany that's according to
Article five understood that every time
and if if you ask that what a Russia has
military capabilities to do so of course
they have they have lots of forces very
close to your stallion border you know
Vladimir Putin saying in in cool parent
in in a press conference at in front of
finished president that they have taken
their forces 1,500 kilometers from
Finnish border which is very close to a
stadium border is of course a nonsense
because I calculated i looked at the map
i did a very quick calculation there is
more than 350,000 russian troops within
range of 1,500 kilometers from finnish
border so you know that that's not about
this message yes the later the natal
will meet this weekend in Russia what
are your expectations my expectation is
to send very clear message continuously
that we will increase our deterrence
level that quickly what does it mean
that means also in addition to the
decisions already taken in Wales this
means a presence in in all of its
territories just like you know and this
is not because we are prettier more porn
tubes a we will have more troops in in
our reach and that's for sure but this
is again to make a distinction this is
not because we are preparing for war
there are lots of Allied presence in in
Germany this is not because Germany
is preparing for war or there are no
nominee is not asking to increase the
troops your country and other countries
are also that means you have the
impression that the danger is getting
higher well I think that it's time to
fully understand that all NATO member
states need allied presence not only
Germany not only Italy not only Belgium
I'm not asking presence at the level of
what the presences in in many of the
Western countries but we think that the
presence should be in all territories
this is the most credible message we can
send to say that NATO is united NATO is
together and you cannot disunite one
country's security from others let its
default you to let us take seriously and
not with symbols about the question the
very high readiness Joint Task Force
which is only made up of 5,000 troop
NATO troop would have taken seven days
to get here in 60 hours the Russians are
here but seven days adds up to 160 hour
that means 5,000 troops reach Estonia
four and a half day too late how could
that be sufficient to defend you against
the run shot first of all the estimation
how fast Russian troops can move what
was yours not mine but 120th but it's
still your estimation but I have good
news estonia has troops as well Estonia
is one of the four or five countries
that actually contributes more than 2%
to national defense we have capable
forces we are ready to stand against any
enemy and of course that said the speed
that our allies can can calm and needs
to be improved it needs to be practiced
and this is all about that we are doing
before Wales the speed was much
slower now we have with widget EF have
moved to next level we still have a lot
of work to do in so that's why German
Foreign Minister frank-walter Steinmeier
recently said quote NATO need to avoid
saber rattling on the eastern flank is
he right I think the most provoking
thing nature could do in relations with
Russia would be to be weak would be not
having exercises would be not having
presence knowing that Russia has a huge
number of troops just other side of the
border if you really know how bloody me
reported thinks the biggest provocation
for him would be seeing that you're weak
and the NATO is not weak NATO is not
only sending units to all of its
countries NATO is showing also with
exercises that it can react quickly it
can stand against any enemy and I'm
confident that this message is heard
were well in Kremlin that actually
there's no actual you know what it
should be completely crazy to to be a
fight against nature because Nature has
made it very clear and we'll make it
even more clear that every bit of NATO's
territory will be defended and there
will be a reaction against the most
important member of NATO America could
have in a few weeks in a few month a new
president things will surely change if
Donald Trump's is elected a president in
the United States he calls NATO quote
obsolete and said quote maybe NATO will
with will resolve and that's okay not
the word thing in the world are you
worried about Trump perhaps being once a
president I'm confident that people in
US will make a smart decision they will
have a good president and US rule
in European security is critical not
only for Estonia but it's critical also
for Germany UK France all of ours it has
been already for more than 70 years so
in this doesn't mean anything more than
70 years Great Britain fell being Europe
was for more than 50 years a member of
the European Union things are
challenging well glad to say that UK
will remain to be a member of nature and
very important member of nature but of
course the u.s. role whoever will be the
president the u.s. role will remain very
very important in in European security
but of course that's also important that
European countries stick to our common
commitment T to keep our military
expenditure at the agreed level but even
other side nobody really fulfill the two
percent of GDP the money which is
necessary is not still there so how can
you rely to an organization that does
not even fulfill their own financial
commitment to really bring security to a
country like Estonia 2015 was the first
year after many where we saw a clear
increase in in defense expenditure in
nature including many of the European
allies and well first of all there are
at least five countries in in nature who
contribute more than 2% Estonia
including a zillion GDP or this
expenditure will be two point sixteen
percent this year I'm very glad that
Angela Merkel but also soul of
underlayer have been very clear on on
saying that Germany has to increase
their military expenditure Latvians and
Lithuanians are growing hair and so it
may I ask you something I'm very shortly
do you believe that Vladimir Putin is a
danger for the peace in this world well
that's a question you should ask
Ukrainians you you could get a very
clear answer I when I will be in there
I would ask them I was talking with you
buy that thing I guess I'm very clear
yes I think that leader of country who
thinks that he can change borders of
sovereign countries by force has done so
in Ukraine has done so in Georgia well I
think there's no question that his
aggressive behavior has made to Russia a
threat and has made all the Democratic
world to stand united against all kinds
of aggressions that includes Ukraine
that includes Georgia and then include
sending a message that even thinking
about doing something similar in nature
thank you very much study wellness thank
you for being on conflicts okay